that's right of all this I could
talk about I'm gonna talk about this
trailer after 20 long years Dumb and
Dumber is finally getting a sequel first
of all I love the title of this movie
it's Dumb and Dumber to that's how it's
built
that's not Dumb and Dumber to that would
be grammatically correct it's not Dumb
and Dumber to as in also because that
also could work it's a movie also like
the last movie so maybe that could know
this is Dumb and Dumber to it's so
stupid
this trailer starts out Jim Carrey he
has long hair and a baby looks like
Charles Manson he's just like he has
been that way for 20 years and Harry
goes in visits of all the time and he's
like God yeah it was all the prank
that's right he has been faking being
catatonic for 20 years that kind I don't
have that kind of commitment say what
you will about that guy maybe he's an
idiot but he's more dedicated than I am
man Jeff Daniels has a daughter nod not
just recently he's 1991 and so now
she's growing up and she's way hot Jim
Carrey is hot furs he's like hey let's
go meet her and that's pretty much the
premise of the movie it's a roadtrip
movie it's the first trailer we don't
see a lot about the movie we just know
the concept you know what impresses me
about this trailer will probably impress
me about the movie is Jeff Daniels I am
a big fan of the newsroom so to me at
this point Jeff Daniels is will McAvoy
he's calm collected he's a wordsmith
he's confident he is badass and at that
point even when speed is on TV I'm like
I can't unsee will McAvoy just will
McAvoy now forever but in this trailer I
didn't see will McAvoy I saw Harry
Caray's there will McAvoy as gods like
Jeff Daniels took all the intellect out
of his brains like no commitments you're
going to see nothing but Harry will
McAvoy is dead I think Jeff Daniels
might just be the best actor ever
and among the montage of nonsense you
see fireworks and that dog buggy car
thing from the first one and you see
them they're being dumb and Dumberer and
the greatest camouflage see the
seriously this was impressive if
you blink you miss it but wait a
frame-by-frame I was like is no he's
right there now if he's wearing like
Charlie days Green Man suit than just
CGI the graphics onto him I'll be
disappointed but if that's legit body
paint that is impressive I love the fact
that Jim Carrey is Jim Carrey in this
movie he's Jim Carrey as we knew him 20
years ago in the 90s out
one point Jim Carrey was the
highest-paid actor in Hollywood this
dude was killing it he did it because
that animated comedy and everyone
loved him and then at a point he started
going for the Oscar and started doing
dramas and he started doing comedy again
people were like we don't give a
you write other stuff because we're
fickle I want to see Jim Carrey in a
movie being Jim Carrey as he was I don't
care if he looks older I'm looking
forward to seeing that in the end
of this trailer holy who didn't
cringe in that straight-up Jim Carrey is
looking for diamonds and he ends up this
old lady's in a bed and he slips his
hand in there and then the case after
accidentally playing OBGYN to this lady
who might just be the sole survivor of
the Ripper murders he pulls his hand out
she's like gonna cross that off your
bucket list it's all and the dust goes I
was like Jimmy clear guys this movie's
probably not going to be great I see
Dumb and Dumber to like this I don't
think the movie needs to be made but I'm
glad it's being made if that makes any
shred of sense whatsoever dude that's it
what do you think about I think it's
gonna be good you think it's gonna be
you you glad it's being made either
way whatever you think comment below let
me know and as always if you liked what
you've seen here and you wanna see more
click right here to see more